comment est ce que le québec se compare
par rapport aux autres provinces aux
autres territoires
les trois quarts des québécois disent
avoir un médecin de famille alors que
l'ontario est une proportion qui monte à
94 % mais attention on parle ici d'avoir
un médecin de famille pas forcément d'y
avoir accès quand on veut cet important
dans médecins en perspective combien de
médecins pratiquent au canada il y en a
environ 80 milles et en fait à peu près
la moitié sont des médecins de famille
le tiers en fait se trouve d'ailleurs en
ontario alors quelle est la proportion
maintenant de médecins pour cent mille
habitants
là encore on va vous donner quelques
chiffres c'est terre neuve et labrador
qui obtient la palme avec 163 médecin
pour 100000 habitants ensuite le nouveau
brunswick la colombie-britannique la
moyenne nationale est à 110 où se trouve
le québec est bien exactement sur cette
ligne de la moyenne nationale ensuite
c'est l'ontario avec 96 médecin pour
soulager les habitants
bon évidemment vous dites ça lasse pas
tout d'avoir un médecin encore faut-il
qu'ils soient prêts à vous recevoir et
lol le système de santé canadien traîne
un peu de la patte
oui parce qu'avoir un médecin de famille
c'est bien mais le voir quand on en a
besoin c'est beaucoup mieux alors qu'on
part en nous avec d'autres pays de l'
ocde par exemple si on revoit un
rendez-vous en 24 heures est bien là 76%
des danois peuvent obtenir ce
rendez-vous qui parfois est crucial
ensuite c'est la nouvelle zélande avec
72 ensuite ça descend très vite la
france 57% des français ont un rendez
vous avec leur médecin de famille en
moins de 24 heures les etats unis sont
en 48 ou et le canada est bien le canada
fait partie en fait c'est le 10e 11e
pays donc tout en bas de la liste avec
seulement 41 % des canadiens qui peuvent
effectivement avoir un rendez vous en
moins de vingt quatre heures avec leur
médecin de famille donc c'est pas fameux
comme résultat et pourquoi qu'est ce que
font les provinces donc pour convaincre
des médecins ne pas s'installer dans les
grands centres seulement mais d'aller
aussi en région alors là évidemment on
n'attrape pas les mouches avec du
vinaigre évidemment ça prend de l'argent
alors là certaines provinces ont des
plans différents par exemple la
saskatchewan offre 120 mille dollars aux
jeunes médecins sur cinq ans pour ceux
qui veulent aller s'établir un peu plus
en région colombie britannique on vous
donne 50 mille quand vous commencez et
après les trois ans vous recevez
cinquante mille dollars
l'ontario il ya des bourses d'études
l'île-du-prince-édouard là encore idées
et financière aux étudiants pendant cinq
ans le problème c'est qu'une fois que
l'engagement est rempli à ce moment là
il vient la plupart de ces jeunes
médecins
grands centres et là évidemment se
retrouve avec beaucoup de roulement et
c'est pas toujours facile pour les gens
en région d'avoir un médecin de famille
est ce important c'est très important
merci de ces informations